the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right everyone let's get started all
right good afternoon on this rainy rainy
sad afternoon so I'm glad we're inside
though
okay so lecture four of six triple 1and
600 quick quick recap of what we did
last time so last time we did a little
bit more string manipulations and then
we saw how you can use for loops over
strings directly right so instead of
having four loops that iterate over a
range so 0 1 2 3 4 and so on you saw
that it was more powerful to sometimes
use for loops that iterate over over
string objects directly so that was the
first half of the lecture in the second
half we started looking at different
ways that you can implement the
different different implementations to
the same problem so we saw the problem
of finding the cube root and we saw some
implementations we saw the guess and
check method and the approximation
method and then we looked at what I
thought was the most powerful method
which was the bisection method and this
one if you remember I played a game with
someone in the audience where I got
where I guessed a number between 0 and
100 and we saw that I was able to guess
that number really really quickly right
using the bisection method and that's
the one that that's the method that
you're going to implement that you are
currently implementing in your problem
set okay so today so that that that's
sort of that sort of finishes
introduction to some of the more basic
mechanisms in Python and today we're
going to talk about how to structure
your programs such that you write nice
coherent code reusable code by hiding
some away some of the details in your
code ok and to do that we're going to
look at these things called functions
all right so just stepping back and sort
of getting a high-level view of how we
write the code so far ok so so far the
way the way if you've been writing code
for your programs is you know you open a
file you type some code to solve a
particular problem given like in your
problem sets
each file contains some piece of code no
you have sequences of instructions that
contain maybe you know assignments loops
conditionals and so on and so on but
really you have one file that contains
each code and you write everything in
that in that particular file right but
this is okay for smaller for smaller
problems that we've been seeing so far
but when you're starting to write large
pieces of code it's going to get really
messy really quickly okay so think about
if you are you know you want to use a
for loop in one part of your code and
you find it useful to use that same for
loop in another part of your code some
point in the future as you're you know
debugging your code you might want to
change your original for loop you have
to figure out all the other places where
you've used that type of for loop for
example so as you're scaling your your
code you'll find it harder to keep track
of of these details okay so this is
where functions will come into play in
today's lecture we'll help you it okay
so if you want to be considered a good a
good programmer in good programming
style would be to not necessarily add
lots and lots of lines of code but
really to add more functionality to your
programs okay so how many different
things how many different features can
your program do rather than how long can
your code be right and that'll help you
later on look at your code if you need
it for a future class and they'll help
others if they want to look at your code
later on if they find it useful okay so
today we're introducing this idea of
functions and functions are mechanisms
to achieve decomposition and abstraction
okay so these are two keywords here that
are going to pop up in today's lecture
and also in in future lectures so before
I introduce decomposition and
abstraction in the context of functions
let's first take a look at just sort of
a real life example so let's take a
projector right I'm using one right now
quick show of hands okay if I give you
all of the electronic components that
are part of a projector right resistors
a fan a light bulb a lens the casing you
know all of the different parts in it
who here would be able to build a perd
vector do I see a hand no oh yeah nice
you can also lie I won't know the
difference but if you can do that I
would be very impressed all right so you
can't really put together a projector
right another show of hands if I gave
you a projector that's fully assembled
okay and I gave you a computer for
example who would be able to maybe
figure out within let's say an hour how
to how to make them work together good
fair fair bit of fair bit of the class
that's perfect that's exactly the
answers I was trying to get at here so
none of us really know how projector
works right the internals but a lot more
of us know how to work a projector right
just given maybe a set of basic
instructions or just intuitively
speaking okay so you see the projector
as sort of a black box right you don't
need to know how it works in order to
use it right you know maybe what inputs
it might take what's it supposed to do
at a high level right take the whatever
is on my screen and put it up on the of
the large screen there just magnify it
but you don't know how it does it right
how the components work together so
that's the idea of abstraction right you
don't need to know how the projector
works in order to use it okay as
abstraction the other half of that was
decomposition okay so let's say that now
given a projector I want to project a
very very large image down on a very
large stage for example this is from one
of the Olympics right it's a stage of
like 10 football fields something like
that something massive right you could
build one projector that's able to
project a very large image but that
would be really expensive and you'd have
to build this one projector that used
for this one time right so instead what
you could do is you could take a bunch
of smaller projectors right and feed
different inputs to each one of them and
as you're feeding different inputs each
one's going to show a different output
and then you're going to be able to have
all of these different projectors
working together to solve this larger
problem of projecting this really cool
edge on a very large stage so that's the
idea of decomposition okay you take the
same the same projector feed it
different inputs it does the exact same
thing behind the scenes but it'll
produce a different output for each one
of these different inputs so these
different devices are going to work
together to achieve the same common goal
that's the idea of the decomposition so
this these were applied to the problem
of projecting large image or a projector
in general but we can apply these exact
same concepts to programming
okay so decomposition is really just the
problem of creating structure in your
code okay in the projector example we
have separate devices working together
in programming to achieve decomposition
you're dividing your code into smaller
modules these are going to be
self-contained and you can think of them
as sort of little mini programs right
you feed in some input to them they do a
little task and then they give you
something back you know they go off and
do their thing and then they give back a
result okay these modules can be used to
break up your code and the important
thing is that they're reusable so you
write a module once a little piece of
code that does something once you debug
it once and then you can reuse it many
many times in your code with different
inputs okay
benefit of this is it keeps your code
organized and it keeps your code
coherent okay so functions are going to
be used to achieve decomposition and to
create structure in our code we're going
to see functions today in this lecture
and in a few weeks you're going to
actually see when we talk about
object-oriented programming how you can
achieve decomposition with classes and
with classes you can create your own
object types like int sand floats you
can create your own object types for
whatever you want but that's later okay
so decomposition is creating structure
in your code and abstraction is is the
idea of suppressing details so in the
projector example remember abstraction
was you didn't need to know exactly how
the projector worked in order to use
and it's going to be the same idea in
programming so once you write a piece of
code that does a little task you don't
need to rewrite that piece of code many
times you've written it once and you
write this thing called a function
specification for it or a doc string and
this is a piece of text that tells
anyone else who'd want to use it in the
future you know other people may be
yourself it tells them how to use this
function what inputs does it take what's
the type of the inputs what is the
function supposed to do and what is the
output that you're going to get out of
it right so they don't need to know
exactly how you implemented the function
they just need to know inputs what it
does what's the output those three three
things okay so these functions are then
reusable chunks of code and we'll see in
a few examples today's lecture how how
to write some and how to call call
functions and as we're going through
today's code I want you to sort of think
about functions in with two different
hats on okay the first hat is from
someone who's writing the function right
so in the projector example someone had
to build the first projector right
someone had to know how to put all these
components together so that's going to
be you writing a function right so you
need to know how to make the function
work and then the other hat is you as
someone as a programmer who's just using
the function right you're assuming it's
already been implemented correctly and
now you're just using it to do something
okay so these are some of the function
characteristics and we'll see an example
on the next slide so functions going to
have a name now you have to call it
something it's going to have some
parameters these are the inputs to the
function you can have 0 inputs or as
many as you'd like function should have
a doc string this is how you achieve
abstraction so it's optional but highly
recommended this is how you tell other
people how to use your function function
has a body which is the meat and
potatoes of the function right what it
does and a function going to return
something it's it computes its thing and
then it gives back spits back some
answer
okay here's an example of a function
definition and a function call okay
function definition is up here you know
I'll just draw here this is the function
definition up here and this is the
function call down here so remember
someone has to write the function you
know that that does something to begin
with so this is how you write the
function the first is whoops the first
is going to be this d EF keyword and de
F stands for it tells Python I'm going
to define a function next is the name of
the function in this case I'm calling
the function is underscore even and the
function name should really be something
descriptive whereas someone who's just
using this function or looking at it can
pretty much tell what it's supposed to
do without a lot without going a lot
farther than that than just looking at
the name okay and then in parentheses
you give it any parameters also known as
arguments these parameters are the
inputs to the function and then you do :
okay so this is the first line of the
function definition and after this
everything that's going to be part of
the function is going to be indented the
next part is going to be the dock string
or the specification this is how we
achieve abstraction using functions
specification or the dock string starts
with triple quotes and ends with triple
quotes and you can sort of think about
this as a multi-line comment it's just
going to be text that's going to be
visible to whoever uses the function and
it should tell them the fault the
following things what are the inputs to
the function what is the function
supposed to do generally and what is the
function going to give back to whoever
called it okay
the next part is going to be the body of
the function we'll talk about what's
inside it in the next slide and that's
it that's all for the function
definition def blah blah blah indented
everything inside the function okay so
this is you writing the function
definition once the function definition
is written you can call the function and
that's this part down here and here when
you call a function you just say its
name and then you give it parameters and
you give it as many parameters as the
function is expecting in this case only
one parameter
okay so what's inside the function body
you can put anything inside the function
body you remember think of a function as
sort of a small procedure a little mini
program that does something so you can
do anything inside the function that you
can do in the regular program print
things up do mathematical operations and
so on the last line is the most
important part of the function though
and it's this return statement that's
what we call it so it's a it's a line of
code that starts with return which is a
keyword and then it's going to be some
value okay notice this is an expression
here I percent 2 is equal equals 0 is an
expression that's going to evaluate to
some value okay and as long as this part
is something that evaluates some value
it could be anything you want and this
line here return something tells Python
okay after you've finished executing
everything inside the function what
value should I return and whoever called
the function is going to get back that
value and the function call itself will
be replaced by that value ok so let's
look at an example
I'm going to introduce the idea of scope
now okay
and scope just means is another word for
environment so if I told you that you
can think of functions as little mini
programs the scope of a function is
going to be a completely separate
environment than the environment of the
main program so as soon as you make a
function call behind the scenes what
Python says is okay I'm in the main
program but I see a function call I'm
going to step out of this main program
I'm going to go off into this new
environment I'm going to create entirely
new set of variables that just exist
within this environment I'm going to do
some computations when I see the return
I'm going to take this one return value
I'm going to exit that environment and
then I'm going to come back to the main
program okay so as you're entering from
one scope to another you're sort of
passing these values back and forth so
when you're entering a scope you're
passing a variable back into you're
passing a variable into the function and
when the functions finished you're
passing a value back to whoever called
it okay so once again this top part is
the function definition and any
arguments for the function definition
are called formal parameters and they're
called formal parameters because notice
they don't actually have a value yet
right in the function definition you're
sort of writing the function assuming
that in this case X is going to have
some value but you don't know what it is
yet you only know what value X takes
when you make a function call down here
so this is your function definition and
then later on in your main program you
might define some variable X is equal to
three and then you make a function call
f of X here is your function call and it
says okay I'm calling F with the value
three because X takes the value three
and then I'm going to map three into the
function the values
our past into the function call are
called actual parameters because they're
going to actually have a value okay
so let's step through this program this
is the small program and see what
exactly happens behind the scenes in the
scope and if you're just starting to
program I think it would be highly
valuable if you take a piece of paper as
you're doing some of these exercises and
you write down something similar to what
I'm going to go through here I think
it'll help a lot and you'll be able to
see exactly you know step by step what
variables take what values and which
scope you're in okay so here we go when
the program first starts we're creating
this global scope okay it's the main
program scope in the main program scope
the first thing that python is going to
see is this part here de f f of X and
then some some stuff inside okay this
tells python i have a function named x
but i don't care what's inside the code
yet i don't care what's inside the
function definition yet because i
haven't called the function yet right so
to python it's just some code just
sitting in the global scope okay so
whenever you see de f you're just
putting some code in there then you go
on to the next line x is equal to three
so in the global scope you now have also
variable x is 3 and then the next line z
is equal to f of X is a function call as
soon as you hit a function call you
create a new scope a new environment
okay so we're temporarily leaving the
global scope and sort of you know
portaling into a new scope where we're
going to try to figure out what this
function is going to do and what it's
going to return so the first thing you
do is you map the parameters so X here
I'm calling f of X with 3 so the first
thing I'm doing is I'm mapping every one
of the parameters in the definition to
their values so the first thing I'm
doing is X gets the value 3
okay next line here is X is equal to X
plus 1 so we're still inside the
function call f so X gets the value 4
we're printing this and then we're
returning X so in the scope of F X is
equal to 4 so we're returning that value
back to whoever called it which was this
function call within the global scope so
this part right here f of X which was
the function call gets replaced with 4
so inside the main program Z is equal to
4 okay and that's how we pass parameters
into the function and we got a parameter
back from the function as soon as the
function returns something the scope
that you were in for the function gets
erased you forget about every variable
that was created in there delete that
scope and you're back to wherever you
started calling it one warning though so
what happens if there's no return
statement I said that every function has
to return something if you don't
explicitly put a return statement python
is going to add one for you you don't
have to do this and it's going to
actually have returned none and oh and E
and none is the special special type not
none is the value for a special type
called none type and it represents the
absence of a value okay what's that not
not as not none is not a string exactly
it's a special special type okay so
before we go on I wanted to go through a
small exercise in spider just to just to
show you the difference that none and
imprinting and returning makes so here
are two functions that I wrote one is is
even with return that's its name so
pretty descriptive it's pretty much the
same code we saw in the slides it just
has this extra little print thing it
gets the remainder when I is divided
divided by 2 and it returns whether the
remainder
is equal to zero so it'll either return
a true or false boolean okay so my
function call is this I'm saying is even
with return with value three when I make
this function call this three gets
mapped into here this variable here so I
is equal to three I'm going to print
with return and then I'm going to say
remainder is equal to three percent two
which comes out to a value one because
there's a remainder one and I'm going to
return whether one is equal to zero
which is false so this this line here
returns false but am i doing anything
with the false not really it's just sort
of sitting in the code here okay so this
gets evaluated to false I'm not printing
it I'm not doing any operations with it
it's just sitting there so it won't show
up anywhere if I want the result to show
up somewhere then I have to print it so
that's what this next line is doing okay
so that one should be straight
straightforward is even with that
returns a little bit trickier but not
too bad
I have print without return inside here
and then I'm going to get a remainder is
equal to I % - and notice that I'm not
have I don't have any return so
implicitly pythons going to add a return
none for me like that you don't have to
add it so when I make the function call
here it's going to do the same thing
except the return in this case is not
going to be a boolean it's going to be
this special none right so this is going
to get evaluated to none again I'm not
printing it out it's just sitting there
if I were to print out the result of
that you'd be printing out this value
none which if I run it you'll see here
it just prints it out right there okay
so as you're doing your next piece set
it's about functions and you're seeing
these nuns popping out in some places
check to make sure that you've actually
returned something as opposed to just
printed something inside the function
right like we did here
okay alright so that's the difference
and the last thing I want to mention
about this is even function is is how
useful it can be so notice so this is
the function as in the slide and once
you write the function once you can use
it many many times in your code so here
I have I'm using the function is even to
print the numbers between 0 and 19
including and whether the number is even
or odd so notice this piece of code here
once I've written this function is even
looks really really nice right I have
for all the numbers in this range if the
number I is even right this is going to
return a true or false for all the
numbers 0 1 2 3 4 if it's true then I'm
going to print out even and otherwise
I'm going to print out odd so if I run
this it's going to do this 0 even 1 odd
to even and so on so notice using
functions makes my code really
nice-looking right if I wasn't using
functions I'd have to put these two
lines somewhere inside here right and it
would look a little bit Messier
so I've said this maybe once or twice
before in Python everything is an object
okay
might not have meant anything back then
but I think you're going to see what I
mean using this particular example okay
so if if in Python everything is an
object and integers are objects floats
are objects even functions are objects
okay
so as you can pass objects as parameters
back and forth as function you know as
function parameters you can also pass
other functions as parameters let's see
what this means so we have three
function definitions here func a func B
and func C and then I have three lines
of code here in the my main program so I
have one called a func a one called func
B and one call to fog C let's trace
through just like in the previous
example and see what exactly happens
first thing I create is my global scope
and I have three function definitions
again I don't care what's in the code
yet because I haven't called the
functions yet okay Python just knows
there's these functions with these names
that contain some code after these
definitions I come to this line here
print func a as soon as I make a
function call I'm going to create a new
scope and I'm going to hop into there
okay inside func a I'm going to go and
look at what func a does it doesn't take
into parameters it just prints out this
this the this message here and then it
it leaves it's done there's no return so
we return none so func a returns none to
whoever called it which was that line
there so that is going to be none
next line this one right here print five
plus some function call again I'm going
to hop into funk be scope and see what
to do there so first I'm going to map my
parameters so - whoops - gets mapped to
Y so inside funk B's scope Y is going to
get the value - that's the very first
thing I'm doing mapping all the
parameters then I'm going to print this
thing here and then I'm going to return
y so inside funk B Y has the value two
and I'm returning to back to whoever
called me okay so this is the value two
and I'm going to print five plus 2 which
is 7 last one this is a trickiest loop
that popped up if you think you've got
it try that exercise but otherwise
follow along print funk see funk a ok so
I see that I am going to enter funk sees
scope so I'm going to look at funk see
duck what funk see does first thing I do
is I'm mapping all the parameters don't
even worry about the fact that this is a
function right now just pretend it's you
know X or something so you say funk a is
going to get mapped to the variable Z
inside funky so Z is Funk see just
mapping parameters from actual to formal
then what do we do inside function C we
print out inside funky and then we
return Z this is the cool part inside
funky Z is funk a so if you replace Z
with funk a this here becomes return
funk a open close parenthesis look
familiar
we did that function call right there
right so that's just another function
call
so with that being another function call
you're going to create another scope and
you're going to pop into that one so
we're one two I guess two scopes deep
we're trying to figure out where we're
going so funk a scope is going to be up
here so what does funk a do it just
prints out this and it returns none so
we're going to return none to whoever
called us which is funky so this line
here becomes return none and so this
line here is going to return none to
whoever called it which was this line
down here oops I didn't mean to cross it
up so that line here is going to print
none so it's if you just go step by step
it shouldn't be too bad to try to map
what happens with with variable names
and informal parameters and actual
parameters okay
that's why I highly recommend pieces of
paper and pens one last thing I want to
mention about scope before we do another
example so there are three sort of
situations you might find yourself in
the first one is probably the most
typical and this is when you define a
function and it's using a variable named
X in this case that's also defined
outside of the function and that doesn't
matter because of the idea of scopes so
inside the global scope you can have
variables X when you're inside a
different scope you can have whatever
variables the variable names you want
and when you're inside that scope Python
is going to use those variable names so
they don't interfere with each other at
all so in this example I've defined a
variable X is equal to 1 and then I
increment it and that doesn't interfere
with the fact that we have a variable X
outside this one's a little bit trickier
I define as this function G and all G
does is access a variable X but notice
inside G I've never actually declared or
initialized the variable X right and
this F I said X is equal to 1
but in here I'm just sort of using X so
this does not give you an error in fact
it's okay for you to do this in Python
Python says okay I'm in this scope but I
don't have a variable named X so let me
just go into the scope of whoever called
me so I'm going to just temporarily hop
out of the scope and see is there a
variable X outside of of me and it'll
find this variable X here and it's going
to print out its values so that's okay
this last example here is actually not
allowed in Python similar to this one
except that I'm trying to increment a
value of X but then I'm also trying to
reassign it to the same value of X the
problem with that is I never actually
initialized X inside H so if I said if
inside H I said X is equal to 1 and then
I did X plus equals to 1 then it would
be this example here F of Y but I didn't
do that
I just tried to access X and then
incremented increment it and then try to
reassign it and that actually that's
actually not allowed in Python there's a
way around it using global variables ok
but it's actually frowned upon to use
global variables though global variables
are part of the readings for for this
lecture and the reason why it's not a
great idea to use global variables is
because global variables sort of give
you this this loophole around scopes so
it allows you to write code that can
become very messy ok so global using
global variables you can be inside a
function and then modify a variable
that's defined outside of of your
function and that sort of defeats the
purpose of functions and using them in
writing these coherent modules that that
are separate ok
that said it might it will sometimes be
useful to use global variables as you'll
see in in a couple lectures from now
okay cool so let's go on to the last
scope example okay this slide is here
and notice I've bolded underlined and
italicized the Python tutor because I
find it extremely helpful so the Python
tutor as I've mentioned in one of the
assignments is it was actually developed
by a grad student here or post grad
student slash postdoc here and it allows
you to go through Python paste paste
code go through it step by step like
with each iteration it'll show you
exactly what values each variable has
what scope you're in when scopes get
created when scopes get destroyed
variables within each scope so pretty
much every single detail you need to
sort of understand functions you know as
we're starting to you can see we've had
a couple questions and these are great
questions so if you're still trying to
understand what's going on I would
highly suggest you take a piece of code
and just run it in the Python tutor and
you should be able to see exactly what
happens in sort of a similar way that
I've drawn my my diagrams okay in all of
the in all of the codes for this
particular lecture I've put links to the
Python tutor for each one of those
exercises you can just copy and paste
those and it'll automatically populate
it with that particular example so you
just have to click step step-step
okay so having made my plug for python
tutor let's go on okay
so here's an example it's going to show
a couple things one is what happened you
know print versus return and also this
idea you can nest functions okay
so just so you could have nested loops
nested conditionals you can also nest
functions within functions so let's draw
some diagrams just like before of the
scopes first thing we're going to do is
when we write have a program we're going
to create the global scope and we're
going to add every variable that we have
and then when we reach a function call
we're going to
do something about that okay so the
first thing in the global scope is this
function definition again in my global
scope I just have G as some code because
I have not called it yet okay I only go
inside a function when I make a function
call so G contains some code so we're
done with 75% of that of that code next
line is X is equal to 3 so I'm making X
be a variable inside my global scope
with value 3 and then I have this Z is
equal to G of X this is a function call
when I see a function call I'm going to
create a new scope so here is the scope
of G with the scope of G I'm mapping
variables to actual actual parameters to
formal parameters so the first thing I'm
doing is I'm saying inside G what is the
value of actual parameter X and X is
going to be the value 3 because I've
called G of X with X is equal to 3 okay
next what I see inside this function so
this is the inside of the function is
this bit here it's another function
definition again since I'm just defining
the function and I'm not calling it all
Python sees is H is some code ok I
haven't called the function H yet
because I'm just defining it here with
DF ok so that finishes this this part
here the next line is X is equal to X
plus 1 so inside the scope of G I'm
incrementing X 2 before then I'm
printing out this line and then I've
reached here H
this is actually a function call and I'm
calling H as soon as I make a function
call I'm creating another scope so I'm
temporarily going out of the scope of G
and going into the scope of H so Python
knows that H contains some code and now
I can go inside H and do whatever I need
to do so the first so H doesn't have any
parameters so I don't need to populate
anything like that in there X does does
define a variable called X which is ABC
it's a string and then that's all H does
what does it return none I heard
murmuring but I think none was the was
what you guys are saying so since
there's no return statement H is going
to return none okay so H returns none
back to whoever called it which was this
code inside G so that gets replaced with
none the thing that I've H the circled
read H here as soon as H returns we're
going to get rid of that scope all the
variables created within it and we're
done with H so now we're back into G and
we just finished executing this and this
got replaced with none okay we're not
printing it out right so this doesn't
show up anywhere it's just there so
we're finished with that line and the
next line is return X so X inside G is 4
so 4 gets returned back to whoever
called it which was in the global scope
here so this gets replaced with 4 so
once we've returned X we've completely
exited out of that the scope of G and
we've come back to whoever called us
which was global scope and we've
replaced Z is equal to G of X and that
completely got replaced with for the
return value
so that's sort of showing the nested
nested functions all right just circling
back to decomposition abstraction this
is the last slide you can see in in if
you look at the code associated with J's
lecture there's some other examples
where you can see just how powerful it
is to use functions and you can write a
really clean and simple code if you
define your own functions and then just
use them later
right and the beauty of defining your
own functions that you can use multiple
times later is you only have to debug
the function once right
I know debugging is not your favorite
thing but you only have to debug this
one thing once and then you can know
that it's right and it works well you
can just use it multiple times all right
thanks everyone